chinese businesses are warning of the
severe impact of shanghai's prolonged
lockdown car makers say they may have to
halt production with their suppliers in
the city unable to produce parts the
vast city's 25 million residents have
been kept mostly at home for weeks now
as the chinese government maintains its
so-called zero-covered approach to
pandemic restrictions shipping giants
are also warning that the shanghai
lockdown has snarled up the world's
busiest container port
well let's get more on this from our
resident china watcher clifford coonan
clifford thanks for joining us in the
studio and just tell us what impact this
zero covered policy is already having
and is going to inevitably have on
supply chains
well it's going to have a major impact
um what we're seeing now is that there's
a lot of goods that are just stuck in
china they can't get out i mean if you
want to get your goods to export them
safe from the port near shanghai
you can't get them out because you can't
even get the drivers to come and bring
your goods to the port so it's a huge
logistical issue at the moment that
they're facing and um some analysts are
saying that it could cause a logistics
snarl that would make that would be even
worse than last year and the year before
so it could be very serious indeed wow
even worse than what we've experienced
in the past couple of years because the
knock-on effects of that have been
extreme and i suppose all of this
together could that have a potential
impact on you know how
much people want to trade with china and
how they want to involve china in their
supply chains yeah i think i think
people are thinking
anew about how they are sourcing
products i think there's a combination
of covet and also the covert zero covert
policy and also the the war in ukraine
and the way china has kind of tacitly
supported that um means that people are
suddenly exposed to geopolitical risks
that they um that they weren't a year
ago and i think people now are looking
at um even companies that have big big
interests in china like vw which is
still very much commissioned to china
and it's it's building a lot of
e-vehicle plants there and batteries
plants there but it's also boosting its
spending in the u.s for example so i
think the the sort of knock-on effect
from these is quite serious you know
we're seeing it spreading into into
other areas beyond china
what about
the knock-on effect for
chinese economic growth because
presumably this is going to have some
sort of
impact on
you know
never-ending growth that we've come so
used to i think so too i mean growth is
slowing i mean we've spoken many times
about the property market for example in
china which is in trouble uh with
evergrand the you know the fact that
it's so heavily indebted um but you also
have
the house prices have stalled for the
last uh two months which means that
there's no relief coming from the
property sector um you're talking about
87 of china's largest hundred cities are
affected by the zero covered lockdown so
it has to have an impact um
the areas that are under lockdown
account for 40 of gdp so as yet um the
government is looking at five and a half
percent growth this year um maybe
they'll meet that because some areas are
proving surprisingly resilient but at
the same time shops are closed in
shanghai you know the only stuff that's
being that's getting out of stuff that's
being delivered um and
we see like air traffic is down 70 on on
a year ago so there's a lot of these
areas of the economy that have been very
vital towards recovery in china that are
suddenly again in in trouble what i find
interesting is we are hearing from
chinese companies you know we're hearing
from huawei and we're hearing from car
makers saying that you know the the zero
coverage is putting pressure on them
it's quite unusual to hear
any any organization within china
speaking out like that is this sort of
pressure going to be enough to
change the policy
i think so i mean there are some signs
um we've had the government has said
it's going to work with 666 companies to
um to help them get through this but
it's basically where the political and
the economic are quite separate as you
know as always in china um but it could
be that the pressure if there's a threat
to stability they will have to intervene
in some way so we have to see now what
they will do in terms of sticking to
this zero covert policy or whether
they'll allow economic interests to come
first okay clifford conan thanks for
staying across that for us
you